- I have some beef officially.
You are, like, losing weight
in COVID you, I found
it. What are you doing?
- Spanx and also...
- You look so good.
- I lost my taste and smell so...
- Oh, that's right!
- So, food is kind of different right now.
- Still?
- Yes.
- So, you, she had COVID
if anybody didn't know,
but, like, that's so, wait, what was,
you did, you were one of the
people that lost all your
- Yeah, I, so, it was about
five days in I'm like,
honey, cause Garth makes
me coffee every morning,
I'm like, I love you but did you like,
is this, this is weak coffee.
I love you but did you put coffee
in here? And, it was just
like that. And so, it's been
about eight weeks.
- What?
- Yeah, so I, it's really
weird, I think this is
how normal people eat.
So, I think they eat when
they're hungry. This is my
theory and then they stop
when they're full. It's weird
because it's so much about
taste and smell and if you
can't smell you don't really
- Crave?
- You just don't and so,
it's now all about texture.
I can tell if something's
spicy, that's about it.
- Still?
- Lots of hot sauce.
- But they say it comes back, right?
- They do say it does, Kelly.
- Oh my gosh! So, this is hard
you're a chef. I'm like what
- And I love to cook, so now when I cook,
I just ask Garth, like
tell me if it needs more
salt and pepper, you know?
- Oh my gosh!
- That's the weirdest thing.
- That's so crazy and he didn't get it?
That's the weirdest thing.
- Well, he's an alien and
I think we proved this.
- No, well, yes we have,
but here's the thing,
I actually know a few couples
where one person got it
and the other one didn't.
- I do, too.
- Yeah, and I'm like,
how does that happen?
- And he was not, like, cause I'm like,
you have to get away from me,
like, you have to quarantine
in another room. You're not,
no, no, we're in this together.
I'm like, honey, I cannot
give Garth Brooks COVID.
Like, you can't get it, and he never did.
- Wow!
- And he had the vaccine.
He didn't have any,
not even a sore arm. He's just
- Oh, I got so sick off mine.
- Did you?
- Just for like 12 hours.
- Yeah. No, he didn't get any of that.
So I just don't think he's, I mean
I knew he wasn't normal,
but he's just an alien.
- Wow. Did he take care of you?
Was he a good doctor?
- He was really wonderful.
- Okay.
- Yeah, he was really great.
- Oh my God. That's
how you know it's love.
Cause I'd be like, are you okay in there?
- Well, I was like, if you
get it, I'm not gonna be,
I'm not gonna sleep in the bed with you.
- Exactly! I'm like, look, I
don't want to keep exchanging
this beautiful thing
- Yeah, like I love you, but no.
- Oh my gosh. That's amazing.